un altar alzado en medio de la calle
palabras anónimas de duelo y ofrendas
para los que murieron mientras estaban
de celebración
durante toda la noche decenas de
personas se acercaron al barrio de
itaeón en seúl el lugar de la tragedia
que enluta a Corea del Sur
me siento culpable vengo aquí de fiesta
a menudo y no puedo evitar pensar que me
podría haber pasado a mí
este habitante de la capital surcoreana
vive desde hace 30 años en el barrio
intenté Llamar a mi hijo muchas veces si
no lograba contactarlo estaba muy
preocupado hasta que sobre las cuatro de
la madrugada finalmente conseguí hablar
con él fue un descanso
las autoridades de Corea del Sur bajo
presión trasera acusadas de no haber
movilizado suficientes policías han
iniciado una investigación
137 agentes estaban en el concurrido
barrio de fiesta a la noche de Halloween
mientras que en la residencia
presidencial cercana al lugar de los
hechos había tres veces más haciendo
guardia y que el año pasado para
controlar las restricciones covid se
desplegaron 4000 agentes en la morgue
nos encontramos con uno de los primeros
periodistas en llegar al escenario de la
avalancha
en un lado de la calle las ambulancias
atendían a la gente y todavía no
sabíamos Cuántas personas habían muerto
y en el otro lado de la calle había
quienes seguían de fiesta totalmente
descabellado
se trata del incidente más mortífero en
Corea del Sur desde el naufragio de
seawol en 2014 donde perdieron la vida
304 personas hechos que llevaron al
entonces
Primer Ministro chun-hon wong ha
renunciar